i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la opinión
pública en el reino unido está siendo
sacudida por el llamado party gates el
escándalo surgido al darse a conocer que
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson ha realizado varias fiestas en
su residencia oficial en el número 10 de
downing street algunas de estas fiestas
incumplieron las propias reglas de
confinamiento impuestas por el gobierno
en el punto más álgido de contagio de
kobe 19 en el 2020 en el reino unido- no
es el primer escándalo que afecta al
premier británico es el más reciente
veamos en el siguiente informe una
recopilación de los momentos más
controvertidos de boris johnson veamos
el primer escándalo que estalló para
boris johnson llegó apenas unos meses
después de su aplastante victoria
electoral en 2019 en abril de 2020 el
nuevo primer ministro y su pareja
decidieron renovar su residencia privada
un donante torri vio al partido
conservador más de 50.000 libras para
las obras una donación que debería
haberse hecho pública pero nunca fue así
más tarde johnson afirmó haber pagado el
mismo
la investigación absorbió a johnson de
cualquier infracción pero le criticó
duramente por no haber revelado
información clave pero el escándalo que
hizo saltar a los medios de comunicación
se produciría en medio del primer
confinamiento por coronavirus en el
reino unido- con la pandemia fuera de
control se reveló que el asesor especial
de boris johnson dominique camins viajó
cientos de kilómetros al norte de su
vivienda de londres para pasar tiempo en
una casa de campo familiar con su esposa
e hijo a pesar de mostrar síntomas de
kobe 19 después realizó una excursión de
un día a la cercana localidad de barnard
caso para según dijo poner a prueba su
vista comentó negó haber infringido las
normas del confinamiento que boris
johnson se tomó con su pareja carb y
simmons en el caribe durante la navidad
de 2019 las vacaciones las pagó el dueño
de una cadena de tiendas de telefonía
móvil pero su donación nunca se hizo
pública el siguiente escándalo que
golpeó al gobierno llegó en noviembre
del año pasado se descubrió que el
diputado conservador owen paterson había
infringido las normas sobre grupos de
presión al plantear cuestiones en el
parlamento en nombre de empresas y una
comisión parlamentaria recomendó
suspender lo durante 30 días pero por
primera vez en décadas los legisladores
encabezados por los diputados tories
desestimaron la recomendación del comité
de normas votando en contra de la
suspensión boris johnson ha sobrevivido
hasta ahora pero podrían las últimas
acusaciones sobre fiestas con alcohol en
el número 10 de downing street durante
el primer confinamiento por comí 19 ser
el último clavo en el ataúd del
liderazgo de johnson el premier siempre
ha negado haber infringido a sabiendas
las normas del confinamiento pero a
medida que se revelan nuevos encuentros
festivos mientras los británicos estaban
obligatoriamente aislados crecen las
voces que exigen su renuncia nadie sabe
cuánto tiempo más el primer ministro
podrá aferrarse a su trabajo
como pueden ver quedan muchas preguntas
que están aferrado al poder está el
primer ministro este escándalo lo
obligará entonces a abandonar su cargo
que tanto respaldo tiene en el
parlamento en donde ha hecho alianzas
que lo han sostenido pero por cuánto
tiempo más precisamente es el parlamento
westminster el que tiene la última
palabra sobre este tema y será el
parlamento el que decida si pide o no la
dimisión de johnson la imagen de ese
político desgarbado e irreverente que en
cierta forma representó un cambio para
los británicos y que terminó de conducir
al reino unido- hacia el retiro de la
unión europea ha cambiado ahora es un
político que se pasa por encima las
reglas engañó al pueblo al negar que no
había estado en estas fiestas y luego
tuvo que retractarse en público incluso
dejó de lado a su majestad la reina
isabel segunda que por los días de
algunas de estas de las fiestas estaba
en pleno duelo por la muerte de su
esposo felipe el duque de edimburgo
johnson ha pasado por alto asesores
colaboradores y el personal de alguna de
las instituciones que son más sagradas
para la democracia británica como la
cámara de los comunes qué es la cámara
baja del parlamento británico como
ustedes pueden ver hay una crisis
política y en el reino unido que vamos a
abordar desde todas las ópticas posibles
caerá a boris johnson lo analizamos en
el debate de france 24 y para hablar de
este tema hemos invitado a ivana
barelles ella es analista internacional
es máster en comunicación política de la
universidad de cardiff nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de londres la capital
británica también está con nosotros es
ar jiménez analista político y también
académico también de la universidad de
cardiff en galés también se une a este
programa desde la ciudad de londres
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en este debate con
todos los comentarios y las preguntas
que tengan lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo ese
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal y les recuerdo que la etiqueta
es numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios y sus opiniones
sobre este tema comienzo entonces
preguntándole al banna vargas en la
ciudad de londres sobre la opinión de lo
sucedido estas numerosas
crisis que se le han venido
presentando en el camino al primer
ministro boris johnson por su forma de
manejarse dentro de los círculos
políticos y la forma en el que el primer
ministro poncho bones johnson ha
manejado la política británica a lo
largo de estos años cuál es su opinión
hola primero muchas gracias por la
invitación y claro yo creo que ha sido
un año sumamente complejo para boris
johnson hemos podido ver esta hipocresía
de un líder que por un lado dice una
cosa y crea ciertas reglas para que la
ciudadanía siga pero que yo descubriera
descubriendo paso a paso como él no ha
ido y no ha ido cumpliendo cada una de
las normas que su mismo gobierno ha
impuesto todas las fiestas las evasivas
las disculpas falsas y obligadas de
boris johnson para mí han afectado
fuertemente la opinión de la ciudadanía
lo que se traduce también en una pérdida
total de la confianza de la gente no
sólo en boris johnson y su mandato y el
de todo su gobierno en general sino
también una desconfianza de la
ciudadanía con todo el espectro político
y eso para mí se suma también con la
desconexión total que se ve porque cada
una de las decisiones que haya tomando
por ello sólo han ido planteando como un
personaje muy marcado de la élite un
poderoso que finalmente viene a
implementar ciertas normas crear ciertas
leyes para después no cumplirlas
nosotros veíamos gente que no podía
despedir a sus seres queridos o no podía
decir adiós y mientras él celebraba este
tipo de reuniones y fiestas en la sede
de gobierno
y qué piensas césar jiménez también allí
en la ciudad de londres gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa césar su
opinión sobre esta seguidilla de
escándalos que han protagonizado en
cierta forma algunos de los capítulos
del mandato de johnson hay en el reino
unido sí bueno muchas gracias por la
invitación santiago primero y claro ese
es quizás la crisis más importante que
tenido el gobierno de johnson hasta
ahora sin embargo hay que tomar en
cuenta que no es una crisis terminal
todavía parece gobierno y aún existe una
posibilidad de que johnson pueda seguir
director de hecho a eso está apostando
en parte porque johnson aún tiene el
apoyo de gran parte del partido
conservador y también sea
a un tema de cálculo político y no hay
de momento un sucesor claro de johnson
se ha hablado del canciller
henríquez unax ha hablado de la ministra
de asuntos exteriores listos pero
ninguno de ellos se ve claramente como
un posible sucesor de john c entonces
eso ha impedido que por ahora el partido
conservador lo dimita como líder o ponga
presión en él está claro por la actitud
de jones al último días que él no va a
renunciar a la única forma de que salga
es o que haya un reporte muy escandaloso
de las fiestas en los próximos días o
que en los diputados del partido
conservador le pidan la renuncia
bueno en ese orden de ideas este ser
continuo con ustedes ya le doy la
palabra a iván a
varios líderes de la oposición también
han pedido la renuncia del primer
ministro pero si hay algunos sectores
dentro de los conservadores que han
mostrado sus discrepancias sobre el tema
y han tratado de alojarse de alejarse y
de tomar una postura muy del lado de lo
que piensa la oposición y muchos
sectores de la sociedad británica que
han rechazado tajantemente estos hechos
sobre todo estas fiestas las últimas que
se han dado a conocer que tantos apoyos
tienen el parlamento que tantos apoyos
tienen al interior de los conservadores
profundicemos en ese tema y ya
terminamos de armar este rompecabezas
con ivana bueno
cuando se habla de apoyos uno siempre
tiene que tomar en cuenta los apoyos
públicos y los apoyos privados
públicamente a gran parte de los
diputados dicen estar con johnson el
gabinete dice apoyarlo en los últimos
días ha habido mucha especulación si los
diputados que no son parte del gabinete
de johnson
que son quienes tienen el poder de pedir
la renuncia
habrían juntado un número de casos
suficientes de cartas se necesitan 54
para llamar a un
la posibilidad de ser religión un nuevo
líder del partido conservador y eso por
ahora no ha ocurrido hay muchos que
dicen que están esperando el reporte de
su rey que es un reporte sobre las
fiestas para tomar su decisión entonces
está eso y es interesante la posición
del partido laborista porque obviamente
públicamente ellos están pidiendo la
renuncia de johnson sin embargo y esto
importante tomar en cuenta que johnson
renuncie no significa que haya
elecciones generales que jones el
renuncio significa que va a cambiar el
líder del partido conservador
recordemos que johnson originalmente así
se transforma el primer ministro de la
forma que fue originalmente para hacer
examen entonces
también para el partido laborista le
conviene de alguna forma que el partido
conservador continúe en esta crisis y
que se alargue porque eso
aumenta las chances de que en una
próxima elección
el partido laborista pueda proponer
segunda alternativa más viable de
goulard empiezan a moverse las fichas
políticas y van a su opinión sobre los
apoyos al interior del parlamento y el
apoyo que pueda recibir johnson al
interior de su partido hay que decir
como lo está mencionando césar que hay
dos investigaciones en curso que van a
dar unos resultados que podría en cierta
forma definir este escándalo o
volver a repartir posiciones como lo vio
usted y van a y yo creo que las cosas
que mencionamos esas son clave en este
asunto pero también yo creo que tenemos
que poner atención al resultado de lo
que va a hacer cada uno de estos dos
informes que estamos esperando tanto el
informe interno como el informe de la
policía metropolitana porque el mismo
boris johnson se ha mostrado claramente
que no está dispuesto a tirar la toalla
y que de hecho planea mostrar el informe
dijo de manera íntegra sin omitir
detalles luego de toda la presión
política que ha recibido de la opinión
pública también durante este último
tiempo así que yo creo dentro de los
próximos días se va a definir y va a ser
clave lo que va a pasar cuál va a ser el
relato final que toma boris johnson con
toda la información que se reciba con
todos los nuevos antecedentes que
vayamos conociendo porque ya hemos
sabido que todo esto ha sido una bola de
nieve que ha comenzado muy pequeña y que
ha ido creciendo y creciendo y que cada
día hemos ido descubriendo nuevas cosas
así que yo creo que el apoyo final de
parte de los mismos conservadores hacia
moriyón sonó finalmente la quitada del
piso de los otros conservadores hacia
boris johnson también va a depender
definitivamente de los resultados que
veamos de las investigaciones que se van
que se están realizando tanto
internamente como la de la policía
entonces yo creo que ahí estamos en un
momento crítico para la situación del
primer ministro y van a usted toca un
punto importante de la posición que
tiene el primer ministro es una posición
que de acuerdo a los hechos que hemos
visto en las últimas semanas es una
postura que cambia y eso tampoco le ha
gustado a los británicos primero negó
rotundamente haber realizado o haber
estado en estas fiestas allí en su
residencia oficial
y aceptó que se había estado y luego le
tocó a regañadientes salir a pedir
disculpas públicamente qué posición
puede tomar entonces a partir de ahora
partiendo de esa hipótesis suya de que
esto es una bola de nieve que va cada
vez creciendo y van apareciendo nuevos
elementos en esta investigación qué
posición puede tomar johnson puede
llegar a quedar completamente acorralado
yo creo que el problema que es que boris
johnson tiene este enfoque político
caótico y volátil y todas las decisiones
que toma y las acciones que lleva a cabo
en su gobierno van de la línea en este
comportamiento yo creo que va a depender
mucho de los antecedentes que vayamos
recopilando de ese informe de cuanta más
verdad se sepa y de que sepamos si se
estaba rompiendo efectivamente la ley o
no porque ya veíamos como los mismos
ciudadanos tenían que pagar multas que
iban hasta las 10.000 libras por romper
ciertas leyes durante la pandemia
mientras que boris johnson realizaba
todo este tipo de reuniones y fiestas
entonces yo creo que ahora se va a poner
a prueba también si ellos los poderosos
de este país son juzgados de la misma
forma que el resto de los ciudadanos yo
creo que esa es la mayor duda para la
gente entonces todo va a depender de la
narrativa que tome morí johnson y de las
decisiones que tome a partir de toda la
nueva información que vayamos
recopilando esa es una de las de las
dudas que tienen los británicos y
verdaderamente
todos son medidos con la misma regla 2 y
todos son pasan por la justicia de la
misma manera eso lo que muchos reclaman
césar e iban a poner sobre la mesa un
punto importante y es este causó
desorden oeste dar un paso hacia
adelante y luego dar un paso hacia atrás
que ha marcado un poco la forma de
gobernar de boris johnson ha sido una
fórmula que tal vez puede que le
funcione en algunos escenarios
que tanto la funcionado a él este esta
forma de gobierno medio caótica muy a su
estilo a su aire conforme a lo que él
quiera ya sus a sus ideas sin tomar tan
en cuenta a sus asesores a las personas
cercanas y gobernar como a él le gusta y
no teniendo en cuenta a todos este
bloque de asesores y toda la
infraestructura del gobierno
bueno siempre depende de como cional ud
por quién uno no puede aplicar con
johnson y los parámetros habituales que
se utilizan con otro político bajo otros
parámetros la crisis actual por ejemplo
habría provocado la renuncia de un
político habitual
johnson no es así y johnson lo que tiene
y puede ser en parte por su experiencia
como actúen al principio de su carrera
como periodista es muy buenas manejar
las narrativas entonces momentos de
crisis por ejemplo ahora está
enfatizando mucho el el programa de
vacunación que fue al menos en un
principio fue exitoso en el reunido y en
los últimos días ha enfatizado también
que
dice que todo este enfoque en las
fiestas es lo que le importa a la élite
metropolitana de londres y que es lo que
entre comillas quieren los británicos
promedio es que los políticos se dejen
de estas cosas y se preocupen de entre
comillas realmente importante y él ha
puesto mucho énfasis a la política
exterior no se ha hablado de que éste no
al momento de hablar de fiestas sino que
está el momento de preocuparse de los
rusos y entonces es importante también
que él está enfatizando ese tipo de
cosas para cambiar la narrativa y para
decir que esto no en verdad un detalle
esto no importa y esto es solamente algo
que a las élites preocupadas de
westminster
son la única en el que le interesa esto
es decir sería parte de esta cortina de
humo todas estas medidas que están
intentando tomar justo cuando europa
está en otro pico de contagio por la
variante o micro
el gobierno británico dice que va a
eliminar las restricciones que va a
volver a la normalidad esto es una forma
simplemente de satisfacer un poco a los
ciudadanos y bajar un poco la calma
mientras él mira cómo solucionar este
tema de las fiestas entonces sí o sea el
gobierno obviamente lo niega el gobierno
dice que todo está eran propuestas que
se tienen es de mucho tiempo pero si las
reuniones de trabajo además dice sí sí
eso nos dice que era eso y que por
ejemplo ahí está pelando mucho a los
votantes conservadores de fuera de
londres con tomando medidas contra
quienes están pidiendo asilo el reunido
etcétera y claro muchos de sus partes
desde como bien dice esta cortina de
humo para tratar de cambiar la narrativa
y decir que las fiestas no sólo
importante queremos un detalle incluir a
fueron una equivocación que sellase el
culpo y que hay que volver a lo que
realmente importa entre comillas y bueno
si bien hay algunos que han
visto de buena manera como el reino
unido ha manejado el plan de vacunación
que fue bastante rápido pensar que el
gobierno se demoró en tomar medidas
cuando ya europa estaba encarando unos
altos índices de contagio y de
fallecidos por el cob y 19 el reino
unido- estaba un poco rezagado pero
rápidamente se puso al día por lo menos
con el tema de la vacunación eso hay que
avalar se lo ha la gestión del primer
ministro johnson pero hay otros que han
dicho sobre todo sectores más críticos
que ha llevado a una y cito textualmente
degradación de la oficina del primer
ministro de la figura como tal y de la
institución como tal y ahora con este
tema de las fiestas y con esa digamos la
falta de respeto que tuvo incluso
incluso con la reina que así lo han
calificado los medios británicos como se
puede tomar
yo creo que la mezcla entre el manejo de
la pandemia que fue catalogado como
desastroso para muchas personas porque
en ningún momento el reino unido fue uno
de los países con mayor cantidad de
muertos por coronavirus más todo lo que
está pasando ahora con el farp y kate
está de alguna forma destruyendo a este
posible legado de boris johnson y que
incluso si es que llega a dar un paso al
costado esto va a tener ramificaciones
políticas para quien sea que sea su
predecesor vencedor porque él va a tener
su sucesor perdón porque él va a ser
finalmente el que va a tener que dar
cuentas y rendir cuentas a la ciudadanía
tal como lo está haciendo y lo debería
seguir haciendo en este caso boris
johnson yo creo que el escenario se le
ha puesto bastante cuesta arriba sobre
todo por el manejo de la pandemia en
primer lugar porque fuimos de los países
con más muertes por coronavirus y
también por las diferentes decisiones
que se tomaron desde un principio de la
pandemia recordemos que en algún momento
boris johnson se puso a hablar de la
inmunidad de rebaño cuando todavía este
concepto no
permitido que se utilizará tan
abiertamente porque habían miles y miles
de personas muriendo alrededor del mundo
entonces yo creo que ahí partió uno de
los momentos más bajos en lo que tiene
que ver con el manejo de la pandemia
luego ya tuvo algunos altos que tenían
que ver con cómo manejó un poco
económicamente todas las ayudas para las
personas pero luego de esto ya se borra
definitivamente parte de lo que ha hecho
porque poniendo reglas y rompiendo las
afecta directamente a cómo la ciudadanía
ha percibido todo el manejo total de la
pandemia de ser banales pro poco que
profundicemos en el tema de las
investigaciones que están en curso
comienzo preguntándoles por su grave que
es la secretaría permanente del gabinete
de gobierno ella está actuando en este
caso como una investigadora y juez de
una investigación interna de estos
hechos ocurridos en downing street
muchos se preguntan si de pronto grave
va a mantener esa postura que ha tenido
el propio primer ministro de calificar
esto como simplemente unos eventos de
trabajo tal vez se mezcló alcohol en
escenarios donde
socialmente pues no se podía salir y mal
visto por esas élites
londinenses o británicas qué piensan
ustedes sobre esta investigación luego
pasamos a hablar de la investigación por
parte de la policía metropolitana de
londres césar le doy la palabra
bueno yo creo que siempre está en una
posición muy difícil ella por todo lo
que se ha dicho una una funcionaria de
trayectoria impecable pero efectivamente
ahí está investigando su jefe y eso
nunca es fácil habiendo dicho eso si
bien existiera un principio un temor de
que la investigación pudiera terminarse
en un blanqueamiento el hecho de que la
policía metropolitana aceptó abrir una
investigación paralela en parte por
evidencia que ha recuperado a su vez que
no ha sido hecha pública
pero que la policía metropolitana
encontró suficiente para abrir la
investigación significa que hay que
puede ser un informe potente para él en
contra de johnson y habiendo dicho eso
hay que esperar para saber también qué
es lo que se publica johnson ha dicho y
ha prometido que se va a publicar el
informe completo pero johnson también no
es un político que es conocido por
cumplir su promesa
recordemos que johnson por ejemplo el
diputado de
la zona donde está el aeropuerto de
heathrow y él siempre había dicho que si
alguna vez
y ha probado a construir una tercera
pista de aterrizaje él se iba a tirar en
contra de las máquinas
excavadoras para impedir eso bueno el
día que se votó por eso johnson estaba
fuera del reino unido- entonces no hay
confianza de que yo soy necesariamente
va a publicar el reporte y es con
respecto al reporte de la policía puede
tardarse semanas e incluso meses
en ese público entonces la puesta de
jones puede ser de de que cuando se haga
público está enterrado al lado de otras
noticias que en ese momento se ven como
más importante y van a su opinión
yo creo que la ciudad y está en una
posición también como decía muy bien
césar bastante
complicada porque hacer esta evaluación
sobre todo a una autoridad tan grande
estudia una investigación es muy muy
difícil pero hasta ahora los informes ha
sugerido que efectivamente ella está en
posesión de fotografías que pueden ser
súper claras respecto a lo que pasaba al
interior de estas reuniones al interior
de estas fiestas y yo creo que ahí lo
más importante va a ser también ver la
reacción de la ciudadanía porque puede
haber un un resquemor una unas dudas
respecto a cuál va a ser el resultado de
esa investigación interna y yo creo que
también está provocando un poco más de
seguridad en la gente saber que la
policía metropolitana de londres también
está llevando a cabo esta investigación
paralela que por supuesto puede obtener
resultados similares pero también muchos
más antecedentes
claro puede traer a la luz una
conclusión es similar estas dos
investigaciones pero también puede haber
opiniones diametralmente opuestas y eso
generaría un poco más de controversia a
todo el caso hablemos ahora del interior
del partido conservador existe esta
figura a mí me llamó mucho la atención
el comité 1922 que consiste básicamente
en un grupo de parlamentarios que se
reúnen semanalmente para ir evaluando
cómo están las gestiones del partido en
torno a la toma de decisión y los
proyectos que están avanzando ellos
pueden votar al interior del partido
para pedir un retiro del primer ministro
en este caso boris johnson allí según la
información ya hay más de 10 cartas
enviadas son 54 en total que tendría que
recibir en la cabeza líder del partido
para empezar a hacer una votación
interna y tomar decisiones hay
precedentes de este tipo de comité que
se haya puesto en marcha cómo funciona
esto esto es algo muy inusual para
américa latina este tipo de
de comités pues prácticamente no existen
no tienen tanto poder y resulta
interesante explicarlo para la audiencia
de américa latina césar su opinión y
conocimiento sobre este tema si el
comité se ha puesto en marcha en
distintos momentos y claro como tú bien
dice se requieren 54 cartas para las 54
cartas no son necesariamente para que el
entonces líder del partido conservador
deje el puesto sino que es para que se
llame a una
competición de otros líderes y si por
ejemplo eso ocurre en este caso
los miembros del partido conservador
tienen que votar por quién sería el
líder y uno de los candidatos puede ser
el director pero si el líder actual gana
esa competición no se le puede desafiar
durante un año entonces por eso es una
estrategia que no se usa muy a menudo
porque si por ejemplo lo hicieron ahora
desafiaron a boris johnson y boris
johnson y gana esa competición interna
él va a seguir siendo líder por al menos
un año más
se le puede desafiar no importa lo que
ocurra entonces por eso cuando
cuando el comité vota por eso
tratan de que no solamente esté en los
54 votos para llamar a este desafío sino
que además tengan la confianza de que
eventualmente
si hay una competición el director del
partido conservador puede cambiarse
claro ivana si hay algo más para agregar
en esta explicación sobre este comité en
1922 en adelante pero también quiero
preguntarle sobre el peso político que
representa esto para los tories para los
conservadores en su imagen en su en su
postura en el parlamento y en la imagen
entre los británicos
siendo el partido político que está en
el poder que llegó pues en unas
circunstancias muy difíciles en el break
sin hacer frente a la pandemia una
recuperación económica difícil y poner
en marcha el país después de haberse
retirado de la unión europea
claro yo creo que todo este proceso ha
sido una cuesta arriba para ellos o para
todo su gobierno desde el inicio
partiendo por todo lo que fue el break
si los acuerdos del bex y las
consecuencias inesperadas que trajo
consigo luego ya la pandemia y todos los
hitos que vimos al principio del
programa y que también crearon este este
ambiente que terminó en este terremoto
político que estamos viviendo en este
minuto y yo creo que eso ha afectado
directamente la confianza de la
ciudadanía por ejemplo yo tengo acá una
de las cifras que por ejemplo el 63 por
ciento de los británicos cree que por
johnson debe dimitir y el 70 duda de su
honestidad entonces yo creo que ahí es
cuando nos preguntamos qué tanto más es
válido que pueda seguir un líder como
boris johnson a la cabeza si tiene el 70
por ciento de las personas que no cree
lo que dice que sabemos que plantea
ciertas cosas crea ciertas reglas pero
después no las sigue y que también se
compromete a hacer ciertas cosas lo
mismo que mencionaba a césar
anteriormente él dijo que iba aa el
informe completo de su grave pero no
podemos estar seguros de que eso vaya a
pasar no podemos saber claro cómo se va
a plantear una vez que veamos los
resultados finales de ese informe y van
a cesar tengo dos temas más sobre la
mesa para allá para la recta final del
programa y es si bien ustedes ya lo han
explicado westminster el parlamento
tiene la última palabra en torno a este
tema que tanto peso tiene ahí la
decisión de los británicos el dolor que
tienen muchos ciudadanos británicos que
no pudieron despedirse de sus familiares
por estar confinados en casa mientras
sus familiares estaban hospitalizados en
pleno confinamiento y en plena crisis de
la pandemia kobe 19 y el primer ministro
estaba en reuniones trade haciendo
fiestas y reuniones con sus asesores
cercanos y personas cercanas a su
entorno social y laboral que tanto peso
tienen allí los ciudadanos que tanto le
van a reclamar los ciudadanos británicos
a boris johnson si continúa en el poder
vamos con iván a
bueno yo creo que se ha generado una
especie de espiral de rechazo de los
ciudadanos en redes sociales y también
de manera presencial muchas veces fuera
de downing street por la desconexión que
ha montado que ha mostrado el gobierno
con la ciudadanía por lo que yo creo que
el gran reto en este sentido para las
autoridades actuales y las actuales y
las autoridades futuras va a ser un poco
lograr acortar estas brechas de
desconfianza y desconexión que se han
generado con la ciudadanía se necesita
urgentemente probidad y responsabilidad
también en la narrativa que por ello se
va desarrollando y por eso mismo creo
que uno de los puntos clave va a ser lo
que va a pasar dentro de los próximos
días y también vamos a ver cómo se va a
tomar la gente el resultado de cada uno
de los informes porque yo no creo que
eso sea efectivamente algo de lo que
está preocupado solo la gente de la
élite del centro de londres sino que
efectivamente está todo el país mirando
hacia las próximas decisiones que va a
tomar el primer ministro es un pulso
para la democracia británica importante
esta situación
la opinión del pueblo por encima de lo
que pueda pensar westminster o a la
inversa usted como lo ve y estoy de
acuerdo con ivana de que a diferencia de
otras polémicas esta polémica si ha
permeado la la opinión de muchos
británico que se puede ver en redes
sociales vuelve a ver también en
programas no políticos hay gente que he
hecho muchas bromas sobre las fiestas de
johnson entonces se muestra que es un
tema que que ha llegado al país y yo
creo que bueno hay que esperar por un
lado qué es lo que va a decir el informe
pero incluso si el informe de beneficios
johnson puede ser que la confianza en él
esté tan deteriorada que igual sea
obligado a renunciar es importante que
acá los británicos pueden comunicarse y
escribirle mails
a sus diputados y parte de la presión
que se ha puesto sobre johnson por
ejemplo del comité de 1902 ha venido de
eso de diputados que han dicho gente de
mi barrio otra presenta demás reclamado
por esto y yo tengo que comunicar eso
porque existe un va a haber elecciones
no generales pero locales en mayo y el
partido conservador está preocupado
en mayo para el cierre quiero
preguntarles a los dos quién puede estar
detrás de todo este caso algunos medios
británicos especulan que detrás de estas
filtraciones podría estar con dominic
cummings que era el asesor estrella de
boris johnson y que salió de su cargo
después de unos altercados con la esposa
de boris johnson dicen que puede haber
sido él el que ha filtrado estas
fotografías de las fiestas qué piensan
ustedes quién pues está detrás de todo
esto si hay una teoría conspiración que
quepa en este caso y van a rápidamente
yo creo que es súper difícil aventurarse
a decir quién puede estar que atrás de
esto en la mayoría de la gente piensa
que puede ser campus pero que también
podría ser cualquiera de las personas
que ha estado en el interior recordemos
que han sido en muchas fiestas por lo
menos 8 fiestas que han tenido
muchísimos invitados y hay gente que ahí
maneja mucha información y mucha
información confidencial entonces puede
haber mucha gente que nos podría incluso
llegar a sorprender en el futuro si se
sabe que está detrás de esto y césar su
opinión si yo estoy de acuerdo que en
imágenes que es difícil especular pero
es importante que
johnson gran parte de la echada la culpa
al servicio civil entonces mientras más
culpa al estrelló más personas dentro
del servicio están descontentas cuando
está ocurriendo y puede ser que algunos
de ellos estén dispuestos a filtrar
información a los medios pues a césar
jiménez y ahí van avargues les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 en toda américa
latina ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
preguntas y comentarios a través de las
redes sociales sigan en sintonía de
france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]